No matter what other movies or TV shows Mark
Hamill makes, he will always be synonymous
with one role: Luke Skywalker.
That's just bound to happen when an actor's
breakout gig turns out to be the lead role
in the original Star Wars films.
Star Wars fans love Hamill for being a part
of their favorite movies, but he's also one
of the most accomplished voice actors in Hollywood.
"Surprise"
In addition to bringing dozens of characters
to life, Hamill is also a funny and fun-loving
guy.
These bloopers from behind the scenes of his
films prove it.
Training day
When Star Wars first came along, nobody had
ever seen anything like it … including the
cast and crew.
With all kinds of ridiculous costumes and
sci-fi props to work with, things tended to
get a little silly on set.
"Well?
How long?"
"Cut!"
And it only got worse when they started playing
around with lightsabers.
"Haha!"
While we've had the luxury of decades to make
fun of lightsabers, Mark Hamill and director
George Lucas had to create those iconic moves
from scratch.
He'd certainly never waved a laser sword around
before, so the process of him learning how
to do it in these outtakes makes him look
very uncool … but it still packs a lot of
charm.
Super what?
Star Wars is a science-fiction movie, set
in space, with lots of ships, star bases,
and alien races, which means it's loaded up
with lots of made-up jargon.
As Luke Skywalker, Mark Hamill certainly got
his fair share of mumbo-jumbo mouthfuls, basically
from the beginning.
"But I was going into Tosche station to pick
up some power converters."
That's in the medium-range of difficult slang,
but in this blooper from Star Wars, Hamill
has a hard time getting down a simple line
that's laced with just one space word.
"Now let's get some distance before that thing
goes… blah blah blah!"
"Now let's get some distance before that things
goes supernova.
How do you pronounce supernova?
Supernova or supernova?"
No lines, no problem
In 1994, Mark Hamill took a break from his
usual roles to star in the space simulator
game Wing Commander III: Heart of the Tiger.
The game was one of the first to make full
use of the then-cutting edge technology of
full-motion video, which put Hamill front
and center in most of the cutscenes.
"You haven't lost your touch."
Wing Commander III featured over two hours
of that kind of thing, which meant a lot of
time in front of the camera for the actors.
Considering the nature of the project, it's
no surprise that things could get a little
out of hand.
"I'm ready to add to that legend now that
you're here."
"F---!
It's the same old a-hole again."
To his credit, Hamill was a consummate professional
throughout the whole thing … even when he
couldn't remember his lines.
"We've got to be on our guard.
I don't know my line, but I want everyone
to think I do!"
Bear-ly scripted
Mark Hamill also shows up from time to time
in interesting indie movies, such as Brigsby
Bear, a dark comedy about the strangest and
most mysterious kiddie TV show possible, co-written
by and starring Saturday Night Live's Kyle
Mooney.
Hamill plays Ted, the father figure of Mooney's
character, and also an evil, human-faced sun
god on the show-within-a-movie, Brigsby Bear
Adventures.
"Careless Brigsby Bear!"
"Impossible."
Hamill is barely recognizable in the part.
However, his voice, and sense of humor, are
immediately familiar when he starts riffing
funny things to say.
"Calm down bro, you're being hella weird."